hello everyone and welcome to another
very nice game you guys requested uh
from round one of this year's julius
bear generation cup and also a very nice
example of why it's called the
generation cup here we have the 53 year
old uh absolute chess legend vasily van
chuk is playing against 17 year old
indian grandmaster pragnanda and it is
uh well quite quite um
an interesting game as it usually is
when both the vassal is playing and when
uh pragmata is playing uh so let's check
it out uh vassal has the white pieces
and he opens with ponte e4 and uh now
just a quick heads up
this game features 17 moves of known
theory of the real lopez so let's dive
straight into it so pawn to e5 knight f3
knight to c6 and bishop to b5 duroy
lopez is on the board we have a6
morphy's defense uh bishop to a4 and now
knight to f6 we have castles and pawn to
b5 now so the columbus variation of the
morphe defense nothing new here bishop
b3 with bishop to c5 and now pawn to a4
we have rooked a b8 and now uh pawn to
c3 we have won the d6 and now pawn to d
for attacking the bishop and bishop back
to b6 we have knight to a3
uh also uh here just eight captures on
b5 and a5 is also played but we've seen
a5 this attempted upon sacrifice so many
times on the channel
that i'm sure even all of you guys know
what this is all about and of course the
vassal is expecting pregnant uh to know
what it is about so he does not attempt
to this he goes for the third most
popular option which is knight to the a3
uh we have castles now by prague a
capture sun b5 a captures on b5 and
knight captures and b5 so he accepts the
pawn sacrifice now vassal is up upon but
prague will have a very very active game
and now uh what's what's going on with
the e4 pawn of course if you capture
this bishop d5 and you just blunder a
knight so you can play that so here
prague just continues development bishop
g4 uh now
attacks the knight puts more pressure on
the d4 pawn and the bush should be back
to c2 now defending the e4 pawn we have
bishop capture on f3 and now g captures
on f3 so this is all very standard stuff
this position happened many many times
in the past knight to h5 uh preparing to
bring the queen into the game and pawn
to f4 now we have queen to h4 and now f
captures on e5 we have d captures on e5
and now uh the position of course has
been reached before like we've said this
is move 17 uh d5 is a known move and
also bishop to e3 countering the bishop
on b 6 is a known move but here we have
kink the h1 by muscle and it is not as
of move 17 that we have a completely new
game so it definitely makes sense to
move the king
out of this diagonal and prepare rook to
g1 to start putting pressure on the
black king if you can develop the queen
and bishop for example play rook g1 rook
g2 bringing the other rook to g1 could
be very good for white
but that's a lot of moves so here uh
prague has to decide how to go about
this does he just play e captus on d4
which is the standard way to do it
probably you would do it in a classical
game but this is rapid so prague goes
knight captures on d5 uh sorry not
knight captures on d5 bishop captures on
d4 uh we have knight capture sunday for
uh knight e captures on d4 and now c
captures on d4 and now comes rook to b4
putting pressure on the d4 pawn uh and
now uh how can vassal deal with this he
plays bishop to e3 he just defends the
pawn uh like i said this is a rapid game
but if this was a classical game i will
show a nice line rook to g1
and now uh
it's just very hard for black to play
this for example if rook captures on d4
you will play queen to f3 and now it's
very hard to deal with this bishop the
g5 is coming
and it's a very very
hard position to handle of course you
can play something like rook d6 and then
if bishop g5 knight d4 attacked the
white queen and the bishop uh very very
crazy stuff to calculate so vassal says
i'm not going to calculate this i'm just
going to play bishop to e3 and i'm going
to play rook to g1 next one i don't have
to worry about my d4 pawn as this will
burn a lot of time so here just the rook
captures on b2 prague wins his pawn back
and now rook to g1 preparing the plan
that we already discussed rogue g2 queen
f3 rocket to g1 and then going after the
black king so queen h3
and now bishop to d3 it makes sense for
the bishop to move now the white queen
can also move the bishop will not be a
target here but also you want to play
bishop f1 and kick away the black queen
from such an active square so knight
before putting pressure on the bishop
and the bishop to f1 we have queen to h4
and now comes queen to f3 again it's a
very interesting position so i will just
show a fun line as of course here prague
is attacking the e4 pawn but also uh
prague might have some ideas of playing
rook captures and just giving up the
rook for this pawn and bishop completely
opening up um
ivan evanchook's kings uh but uh for
example rook g2 is incredibly strong you
just prevent rook captures on f2 and you
don't care about the e4 pawn because
also the the knight here would be uh
hanging and if prague just tries to
force matters by giving up a knight
let's say queen captures and knights the
c2 now attacking the rook and the bishop
with some ideas of bishop capture spawn
captures and then you open up the uh
king side it doesn't really work queen
g5 goes for checkmate and after g6 just
rookie d1 and nothing to worry about
here now knight captures queen can also
capture uh you're just down too much
material of course white would be
completely winning here so it is
possible but it's very very
hard to calculate so vassal just plays
queen f3 he defends the pawn here and
now knight to f6 we have pawn to e5 now
chasing the knight away 94 and now
bishop to e2 and this is a very
important move as prague was attacking
the f2 pawn many times so here uh by
placing the bishop here the rook no
longer attacks f2 now you're playing
rook g2 rook g1 and you are going after
the black king so rook g2 we have pawn
to h5 prague has to figure out a way how
to continue this attack because if he
doesn't uh he he he will just be worse
so rook to g2 we have knight to d5 and
now rook ate the g1 preparing the rook
captures on g7 g6 by prague and now
vassal plays bishop to h6 it goes after
the rook
also you could consider a move like
bishop to c4 here uh black basically
resigns uh but there is there is quite a
lot to calculate the the knight is
hanging and also just rook captures on
g6 even even if you defend it with
knight e7 white can still play rook
captures on g6 and if knight captures
queen f5 uh you are preparing rook
captures also queen captures as the f
pawn is pinned also the knight is uh is
attacked so not all that much to do here
but you could also go for real captures
in g6 right away for example uh king h7
now you play rook to h6 check king goes
with the g7 now rook captures an h5 very
very unpleasant stuff here for uh for
black there's just no way out if knight
captures an f2 just king g1 and if ruby
one checking g2 there's no way out of
this you will have to trade queens here
otherwise you're getting checkmated uh
for example uh captures captures now
rook g5 check and also
uh the knight goes um
and now it's you will have two bishops
for a rook and of course the position is
completely winning for uh for white but
okay after g6 we have bishop to h6 going
after the rook which is also fine uh
rook f the b8 and now pawn to e6 by
vassal
uh queen to f5 again always a
possibility uh as the the g pawn is
pinned so here knight d to f6 uh and now
he captures an f7 with check king
captures and bishop back to e3 uh now
again defending the f2 pawn we have g5
by prague really just relentlessly
attacking here
it's incredible how proc is keeping
everything together and now uh vassal
played rook captures on g5 and with this
move he single-handedly uh delivers uh
prague all of the advantage he had right
back to him uh because if you just play
bishop captures on g5 which seems like a
you know a reasonable idea uh there's no
good reply because after knight captures
you're going to first move the bishop
you don't want to bishop to hang here so
just bishop c4 and after the king moves
now you play rook captures on g5 and
there's no saving this position if row
captures an f2 of course this is
possible just rook g7 check king d8 and
now you go for checkmate rook g8 to
check you give up the rook knight
captures queen d5 check and whatever you
play uh you you get checkmate king e8
rook captures with check uh rook to f8
or you move the king you are getting
checkmated out of the way queen f7 check
here rook captures and f8 this is
checkmate so this is uh the way to go
however vassal played rook captures on
g5 and it seems like it's the same idea
uh but look at this process knight
captures and g5 uh vassal plays bishop
to c for check now expecting prague to
move the king so he can capture on g5 uh
but prague just says nope knight the e6
so prague captured on g5 with the knight
and now with that same knight he blocks
check from the bishop uh this is
something you would uh see if you were
playing chess in a bar i remember when i
was uh you know still playing chess at
bars regularly uh this uh you know kind
of thing happened very very often uh but
yeah okay now uh vassal can still hold a
draw if he for example captures captures
queen c6 is enough for a draw but he
goes pawn to d5 uh he still wants to win
this game but now prague just picks up
the bishop as well uh queen captures in
c4 d captures an e6 with check queen
captures an e6 and now queen to g3
hoping to get some action along the g
file uh but queen to c6 with check queen
we have pawn to f3 and now just rook to
g8 and he was in this position on move
38 that vastly when chuck resigned the
game
as there is nothing more to be done here
the queen is attacked and once you move
the queen doesn't really matter where uh
you can just trade here rook captures
bishop captures and as you can see
uh
uh prague is up a full rook and there is
no
way for for us to even threaten prox
king at f7 so of course uh it makes
sense for him to resign here you know
vassal wasn't low on time uh so uh and
that's not the reason that he blundered
in the final position he had like or
even in the position that he blundered
he was like a minute up on the clock
prague was under a minute the vassal was
over over a minute so it wasn't really a
time issue was just uh
just a a you know a chucky moment that
didn't go uh his way
so yeah that's the game hope you guys
enjoyed it really nicely played by both
of them but really you know just uh pure
uh uh perseverance and resilience by
prague just withstanding all of this
pressure and you know waiting for for
russell to make a mistake and as soon as
he made one just i mean it's beautiful
uh here rook captures and g5 knight
characters and then of course uh in your
mind the king moves and everything is
going your way but prague just picks up
the knight and just moves in there like
what what what did i just do
but yeah that's chess
uh yeah so yeah
that's the game i hope you guys enjoyed
it very nicely played by prague i would
like to thank matthew garner luke
longbone joy tyler laura york and
marcelo de barros for contribution to my
channel thank you a lot i really
appreciate it as usual you can check two
of my previous videos here thank you for
watching and i will see you soon
continuing the coverage of the holy
spirit generation cup uh until it
finishes most likely uh so thank you all
i will see you soon and have an
excellent rest of your day and use
hashtag suggestion if you have a game
that you would like me to cover that is
very nice for others to see
see you soon